hey hulu fans it's cara delevingne and i
play alice in the hulu original series
only murders in the building things are
more mysterious than ever at the
arconius so i hope you're just as
excited as we are for season two while
you're here check out the rest of what's
coming to hulu this month
we need to find a real killer
we can't be seen breaking into
apartments no one has to see us breaking
in we are getting the hang of this
absolutely you can tell it's our second
season
being brave means that you aren't afraid
to be scared
because a lot of the times the scariest
things are also the most important
like admitting who you love
[Music]
or who you are i've never had an orgasm
there are nuns out there with more
sexual experience than me it's
embarrassing you want me to brush my
teeth what's the oldest person you've
ever done it with 82 82 yes 82. nancy
okay i'm feeling a bit better now you
think that if you're vulnerable for just
one second that it's all gonna come
crashing down oh my god my baby's
drowning i don't think i want to be
implicated in this
your rescue team
not assassins what are we gonna do
[Music]
big things have small beginnings
[Music]
we had the vision to see what was going
to happen before it happened
[Music]
you don't know how lucky you are that
you got somewhere you're going
what we're going to be doing
is what i call channeling
it's an incredibly dangerous process
it's also one of the most powerful tools
that has ever existed
watch some lucky shoppers take home
extraordinary items
jerky anyone not the stewart is a
high-class hoarder no pushing no shoving
it's the greatest rescue dog competition
in the history of television it's the
only rescue dog competition
[Applause]
this is where the masterchef magic
happens
you just blew it out of the water
[Applause]
send me back to school
[Music]